allez on se voit de moins en moins d'un
mois à l'école ma mère et ma mère avec
moi tour et vous bonjour ma mère certes
ça va hein
six mois ça gaze mouassa gaza but à gaza
masques à gaz mais tout va très bien
madame dollinger pas à plaindre
forcément dommage d'organismes dans la
cave d'un bâtiment une super méga giga
bout on sera 750 y aura plus de monde
dans ma cave et dans tout le département
étaient étaient et tout ça pour être
prêt pour sa belle gueule pour s'y
opposer
je vous ai pas dit j'ai rencontré la
femme de ma vie j'ai arrêté de cet été
dans mon lycée ce matin et il a été
magnifique modèle à l'avancé j'avance
yal'avant sièges d'avancé à l'avancé
j'avançais chou fleur chou fleur chou
fleur chou fleur et monde et on s'est
croisé s'est croisé la laci l'âge et les
films tels ces sommes j'ai mis ça sent
bon l âge là je m'apprêtais à aller lui
acheter des fleurs mais j'ai pas que tu
aies j avais un stylo je vais craquer m
je vous lis les crises d'accord vous
dire chers geneviève geneviève schehr
geneviève j'ai je me choque ce n'est pas
parce que j'avais pas trop combien le
premier à la base franchement
après je me suis dit au diable l'avarice
elle quand on aime on ne compte pas
chers jeunes viennent la première fois
que j'étais venu en bas de mon hlm
je me suis dit ça y est c'est toi que je
lève je ne voulais plus rien faire j'ai
perdu la tête temps je ne voulais même
plus jour bas ce cas je le sais pourtant
que notre amour est impossible d'un
point elle tempéré policiers
s'inquiétait pas plus et pas un policier
et moi je suis la cible mais j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] c'est psychologique que
notre amour vaut bien une nuit chez les
flics et j ai aussi les flics je trouve
chez les flics c'est ça que je la fais
un bon gars tous avaient le moral que
changer
et être moine salut combattu tu veux pas
regarder même pas répondu gysi que de
moi tu voudrais jamais plus ça fait bien
quand je suis non franchement
franchement vous n'avez jamais plus
jamais plu et j'ai demandé qu'est ce que
tu as fait tu me dis qu'est-ce qui
faisait hier soir crochet sur mon
premier à regarder à travers la fenêtre
mal fermée jack rogers j'étais fait
j'étais grille et il fallait à tout prix
que je lui dise que je n'avais pas me
voir à travers sa chemise
et puis m'a dit tu suivi le jour
influent dans mon garage commencé seul
c'est claudio excusez moi il faut que je
change de page tu vois pas répondu cette
fois ci je le savais c'était vraiment
foutu là en regardant droit devant la
tête bien posée j'ai décidé de lui dire
combien je l'aimé
geneviève geneviève je t'aime beaucoup
150 aux antilles via ma surprise party
je me lève je te dis encore viens chez
moi j'aime bien j'ai besoin de ton corps
ouais
bravo pour isa soir entre nous si avec
ça je me fais pas ci un peu de ça je me
fais pas et pas paul geerts et
baudelaire ouais ça fait ça ça m'a fait
pas état prospère du centenaire de la
salvia mais il est trop jeune et il
vient nous interpréter un bout de son
sketch qui s'appelle l'optique avec sa
mère voilà